today's topic is random variables random
variables are absolutely fundamental
concept in probability theory but before
we get into officially defining them and
so on let's start off with an example
that in fact is a game because that's a
fun way to start so we're going to play
the bigger number game and here's how it
works
well there are two teams and team one
has the task of picking two different
integers between 0 & 7 inclusive and
they write a 1 into drawn one piece of
paper and the other integer on the other
piece of paper they turn the two pieces
of paper face down so the numbers are
not visible and the other team then sees
these two pieces of paper whose other
side has numbers different numbers
written on them sitting on the table
what team 2 then does is picks one of
the pieces of paper and turns it over
and looks at the number on it and then
based on what that number is they make a
decision
stick with the number they have or
switch to the other unknown number on
the facedown piece of paper and that'll
be their final number and the game is
that team two wins if they wind up with
the larger number so they're gonna look
at the number on the paper that they
expose and they're gonna try to decide
whether it looks like a big number or a
little number if it looks like a big
number they'll stick with it if it looks
like a little number they'll switch to
the other one that they hope is larger
so which team do you think has an
advantage here
if you've course if you've read the
notes you know but if you haven't been
exposed to this before it's not really
so obvious and what we encourage in what
we used to do when we ran this in real
time in classes that we would have
students in teams split their team in
half one would be team one and the other
would be team two and they play the game
a few times see if they could figure out
who had the advantage and if you have
the opportunity this might be a good
moment to stop this video and try
playing the game with some friends if
they're around otherwise let's just
proceed and see how it all works so this
is the strategy that team two is going
to adopt they're going to take this idea
about big and small that I mentioned
and and act on it in a methodical way so
they're gonna pick a paper to expose
giving each paper equal probability so
that guarantees that they have a 50/50
chance of picking the big number and a
50/50 chance of picking the little
number whatever ingenuity team one tried
to do on which side of the piece of
paper was on the left and which was on
the right it doesn't really matter if
teams who simply picks a piece of paper
at random there's no way that team one
can try to fake out team two on where
they put the number okay the next step
is that team two is going to decide
whether the number that they can see the
exposed number is small and if so it
they switch and otherwise they stick so
that is they're gonna define some
threshold Z where being less than or
equal to Z means small and being greater
than Z means large the question is how
do they choose Z well a naive thing to
do would be to choose e to be in the
middle of the interval from zero to
seven let's say you choose Z equals
three so there would be three numbers
like four numbers less than or equal to
Z and four numbers greater than Z but of
course as soon as team one knew that
that was your Z what would they do well
they would make sure that both numbers
were on the same side of Z if your z was
three they would always choose their
numbers to be say zero and one and that
way when you were switching your Z would
tell you that you had a small number you
should switch to the other one and you'd
only have a 50-50 chance of winning so
if you fixed that value of Z team two
has a way of ensuring that you have no
advantage you can only win with
probability 50:50 and that's true no
matter what Z you take if team one knew
what your Z was they would just make
sure to pick their two numbers on the
same side of your Z and then your Z
wouldn't really tell you anything you'd
switch wrists or stick in both cases and
you'd only have a 50/50 chance of
picking the right number so what you do
and this is where probability comes in
is you pick
in a way that can't be predicted or made
use of by team one you pick Z at random
could be any number from zero to seven
not including seven including zero and
that is your number is either 0 1 2 up
through 6 and being less than or equal
to Z means small and being greater than
Z means large and when you see a small
number you'll switch and when you see a
large number you'll stick but what's
gonna be large and what's gonna be small
is gonna vary each time you play the
game depending on what random number Z
comes out comes out to be so let's
analyze your probability of your team
what's the probability that you're gonna
win now well let's suppose that team 1
picks these two numbers we don't know
what they are but they have to pick a
low number that's less than a high
number so these two numbers are at least
1 apart they can't have the same number
on both pieces of paper otherwise it's
clear that you are not gonna be able to
pick the larger and that would be
cheating ok so there's two different
numbers so one of them has to be less
than the other we don't know how much
less might be very a lot less might be
only one less but low is less than high
ok now we can consider three cases of
what happens with your strategy the most
interesting case is the middle case that
is when your Z which was chosen at
random happens to fall in the interval
between low and high that is your Z is
strictly less than high and greater than
or equal to low and then in that case
your Z is really guiding you correctly
on what to do if you turn over the low
card then it's gonna look low because
it's less than or equal to Z so you'll
switch to the high card and win if you
turn over the high card it's gonna be
greater than Z so it'll look high and
you'll notice stick with it so in this
case you're gonna you're guaranteed to
win if you were lucky enough to guess
the right threshold between low and high
you're gonna win and so the probability
that you win given in the middle case
occurs is 1 now what about the middle
case how often does that happen well the
difference between low and high as it
least one so there's guaranteed to be
one chance in seven that your Z is gonna
fall between them and it could be more
if low and high are further apart but as
long as they're at least one apart
there's a 1/7 chance that you're gonna
fall in between them
ok now in case H that's the case where Z
happens to be chosen greater than or
equal to the high number that team 1
shows in other words Z is bigger than
both numbers that team 1 chose and put
on the pieces of paper well in that case
Z just isn't telling you anything so
what's gonna happen is that both numbers
are going to look high to you sorry both
numbers are gonna look low to you
because they're both less than or equal
to Z so you'll switch and that means
that uh you'll win if and only if you
happen to low turn the low card over
first
well that's 5050 so the probability that
you win given that Z both cards are on
the wrong side of Z on the low side of Z
you win with half the time and
symmetrically if Z is less than the low
card that is Z is less than both cards
chosen by team 1 then they're both gonna
look high and so you'll stick and that
means that you'll stick you win if and
only if you happen to have picked the
high card there's a 50/50 chance of that
so again in this case that Z makes both
cards look high or Z itself is low team
2 you win with probability 1/2 well
that's great because now we can apply
total probability and what total
probability tells us is that team 2 wins
on the is the probability that they win
given case M times the probability of M
plus the probability that they went
given not the middle case times the
probability of not the middle case but
we figured out what these were or at
least inequalities on them because um
there's probability one that you'll win
1/7 of the time and there's probability
1/2 that you'll win the other the rest
of the time the others
seventh of the time you're gonna win 4/7
of the time the probability that you win
playing your strategy is 4/7 it's better
than 5050 you have an advantage and
whether that was a priori obvious or not
I don't know but I think it's kind of
cool okay you win with probability 4/7
now um team toe has the advantage and it
and the important thing to understand is
it does not matter what team does no
matter how smart team one is team two
has gotten control of the situation
because they picked the which piece of
paper they picked at random fifty-fifty
so it doesn't matter what strength he is
strategy team one used on where they
placed the numbers and they chose Z
randomly so it again it doesn't matter
what numbers team one chose team two is
still gonna have their one seventh
chance of coming out ahead which is
enough to tip the balance in their favor
it's interesting that symetrically team
one also has a random strategy that they
can use which guarantees that no matter
what team to does they team two wins
with probability at most 4/7 so either
team can force the probability that team
two wins to be at most four sevenths and
at least 4/7 so if they both play
optimally it's gonna stay at 4/7 and
that's again true no matter what team -
does team one can put this upper bound
of 4/7 on it so and essentially we can
say that the value of this game the
probability that team two wins is
optimally for both is 4/7 okay now what
is this game got to do with anything
with our general topic of random
variables well will be formal in a
moment but informally a random variable
is simply a number that's produced by a
random process and just to give an
example before we come up with a formal
definition the threshold variable Z was
a thing that took a value from zero to
six inclusive each with probability one
seventh so it was producing an
by a random process that shows a number
at random with equal probability if the
team too plays properly uh at random
picking which piece of paper to expose
then the number of the exposed card or
more precisely whether the exposed card
is high or low will also be a random
variable um and if team one plays
optimally the number on the exposed card
is gonna be a random variable that is
team one in their optimal strategy that
puts an upper bound of four sevens is in
fact going to choose the two numbers
randomly so the exposed card was going
to wind up being another random variable
a number produced by the random process
and likewise the number of the larger
card if team one play picks it's larger
and smaller cards randomly it's going to
be another example of a number produced
by a random process and likewise the
number of the smaller card so that's
enough examples this little game has a
whole bunch of random variables
appearing in it and in the next segment
we will look again officially what is
the definition of a random variable